he is a key ps montre la dynamique de
l'écosystème paris saclay en rassemblant
l'ensemble des acteurs socio économiques
locaux
cette année neuf start up ont été mises
en avant
les entrepreneurs beach tout d'abord
leurs projets puis les présentes à des
investisseurs ou des structures
d'accompagnement intéressons-nous deux
jeunes créateurs d'entreprise qui nous
parlent de leur projet suit mathieu
abelli chanteur d'opéra à l'origine et
j'ai créé le réseau social
opéra musique art qui est le premier la
première plateforme pour le monde de la
musique classique et de l'opéra
j'ai contacté le réseau de business
angels financé technologie étant dans
les environs étant hébergés aux ouailles
de
de massy saclay donc lors d'une
rencontre j'ai pu entrer en contact avec
le réseau est tout naturellement ils
m'ont proposé de participer au concours
présenté aucun musica et ça s'est bien
passé voilà donc jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je suis pas issu du mieux de
la technologie mais le opéra musique
casse et
l'occasion l'opportunité en fait que les
deux univers de l'innovation
technologique et de la musique classique
se rencontre puisque dans mon équipe il
ya également des ingénieurs
donc il ya aussi possibilité d'innover
évidemment dans l'industrie de la
musique et plus particulièrement dans le
domaine de nous placer
uranium c'est quoi en fait uranium c'est
une plateforme qui permet de créer des
avatars 3d pour des jeux vidéo des
applications de réalité virtuelle
réalité augmentée en fait il ya des
téléphones qui sortiront bientôt qui
seront équipés d'une technologie de scan
3d et gens pourront avoir leurs oeufs en
fait leur représentation en 3d et nous
on transforme ça on avatar universel
j'ai comme un avatar sur radio mais je
l'utilisé dans des jeux dans une
application dizaine en 3d je me retrouve
avec des gens réalité virtuelle
on est une premier prototype en avril
et c'est d'ailleurs à ce moment là qu'on
a été incubés à télécom sudparis ces
raisons pour laquelle on est ici
aujourd'hui et depuis ça on a justement
eu pas mal de pas mal d'accomplissement
parce qu'on a surpris en place d'une
plateforme qui en bêta que les gens ont
pu tester qui nous a permis d'avoir des
relations avec des entreprises des
géants de la tech en fait ce qu'on
n'avait pas du tout le paravent
territoire très intéressant fait pour
nous ça a joué un rôle clé pour la
partie accompagnement parce que c'est
via notre incubateur qu'on a pu avoir
des mentors qui tous les deux mois en
fait nous mettaient la pression qu'il
fallait les questions qu'il fallait pour
qu'on puisse aller de l'avant et ça pour
nous c'était hyper clé pour pour
justement qu'on est dans le bon sens